with themselves they have to come to the  arena in separate cars they can't have  dinner or lunch or breakfast is random  i think it's more of the defensive  assignment against west brook and  then bradley beal julius randle two for  two from downtown  take a look at randall though  uncontested another three balls so  westbrook will turn the ball over  players from germany randall  left wide open randall for three three  for four barrett almost  lost his paint right there to help pick  it up the pass is deflected  excuse me that was peyton rantal with  another three  fourth three-pointer for julius randle  [Applause]  julia's right  three and a half gone by randall again  julius randle from way down  the watson he's feeling it fires another  one bang  julius razzle does it again continues to  pour it on  and then his last heat check was a ufo